John Perry on behalf of Mr tadarius Bean
at this time we waited a former evening
of the indictment office the court a
plea of not guilty
back there yes on behalf of my client
Justin Smith Charles Summers uh we uh
interesting uh waiting for more even
indictment and here in Cleveland
reporting judge on behalf of Mr Mills
will be away from Oregon to be indicted
through a not guilty police
Jeremy each of your attorneys have
entered please of not guilty on your
behalf understand that despite
everyone's best effort this case may
take some time your attorneys are going
to be receiving the discovery depending
on how voluminous the discovery is it
may take some time for the state to
collect us all to turn over to your
attorneys for your attorneys to review
that Discovery to prepare their motions
and prepare their case
so be patient work with your attorneys
cooperate with them meet with them go
over the discovery make sure that if
there are any delays that these delays
aren't on account of any of your actions
to those also in attendance as I've
explained to the defendants now this
case can't take some time so we do ask
for your patience your continued
patience your continued civility in this
case we understand that there may be
some
High emotions in this case but we ask
that you continue to be patient with us
everyone involves wants this case to be
concluded as quickly as possible but
it's important for you all to understand
that the state of Tennessee as well as
each one of these defendants have a
absolute right to a fair trial and I
will not allow any behavior that could
jeopardize that right
so with that being said we thank you all
for being present
uh State understanding that there may be
some discovery that needs to be
collected we are going to continue this
case out a little bit further to make
sure that discover is concluded we're
going to reset this matter until May 1st
from 9 A.M
state is there anything else counter the
only other thing on behalf of the state
is to have a protective order as to each
of the defendants to allow certain
digital Discovery video evidence to be
provided
any objections
thank you John
this mess is there anything else on
behalf of your client no your honor I
hope we did follow our motion for
Discovery this morning
about anything on that you're fine Mr
Perry no your honor but we did file a
motion for ill particular sort of rule
7c Timothy rules so I remember receipt
this is Daniel nothing further this
morning your honors thank you this
summer how many programs
all right gentlemen we'll see back here
May 1st